welcome back to SEO foundations in this
video we're going to talk about a
general model of search engines the
process by which search engines deliver
relevant and valuable search results
requires multiple intricate phases in
order for SEO s to be successful they
must understand at least the basics of
this process in this lesson we will
discuss the four major parts of the
process first we will learn how search
engines crawl the Internet
next we will learn how they store web
data thirdly we will learn how they
process and organize data and lastly we
will learn how they provide users with
relevant search results
list and describe four major search
engine processes described how crawlers
find and access information online
explain how search engines store web
data describe the process of how search
engines deliver relevant results in
order for search engines and SEO to work
together
SEO s need to have an understanding of
how search engines work now I'll be the
first person to tell you that this is an
extremely complex process so what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna simplify it
into four vague categories and we'll go
into each of these categories to give
you a little bit more details but for
now the four categories are crawling
storing processing and indexing and
ranking when you understand these you
have a more complete model of how search
engines work so you're able to do your
job in a much more proficient manner at
the root of every search engine is
software in this phase words can talk
about one kind of software it's
something we call crawlers or bots or
robots or spiders now this is software
that does one thing but does one thing
very very well it goes to a specific
website and downloads all of its
contents back onto the server's of a
search engine and then clicks on every
single link on that web document goes to
the corresponding page downloads all of
that content and there repeats the the
process by clicking on all of those
links and go into the corresponding
pages in theory by doing this it crawls
the entire Internet now sit back and
think about that for a second think
about how big the internet it is and how
quickly it's expanding you'll have some
kind of idea of how complex this is but
that's just the basic idea of what a
crawler or a spider does it actually has
a whole lot of traps that that has to it
has to a avoid the biggest one of these
is infinite loops now this is something
I see all the time
what I'll happen is a crawler goes to
something like a calendar application
online and it goes to the next year link
and then I'll click to the next year
link and then I'll click to the next
year link and it gets stuck because
those links are gonna go on forever it's
gonna count up into infinity so the
crawl itself needs to know and it needs
to be smart enough not to get stuck in
the infinite loops that are all over the
internet so what does this have to do
with SEO exactly well SEO s do have some
influence on this it's important for us
to understand and make sure that the
crawlers do not go to protected files
something that should be password
protected for example or maybe sensitive
information
Social Security numbers so luckily for
us most of the time with search engines
come to our websites they'll identify
themselves they'll use a user agent like
Googlebot or Bing bot so we can know
that hey this is not a normal user this
is a search engine now this is
unfortunately been abused in the past
and so search engines will crawl our
site both identifying themselves and
sometimes just to double-check
they will not identify themselves they
do this so that SEO and other marketers
don't take advantage of this but it's
something that we need to be aware of
that when we see a crawler most the time
it really is a crawler but some of the
time it may be a crawler even if we
don't know that that it is the next
phase and this is what we call store so
after the crawlers have done their work
the data that they download needs to be
stored somewhere so this happens on the
search engines servers this is actually
stored all around the globe but the
general idea here is that it's stored on
servers and they've made a copy of your
website so we have accessed his copy
it's something called the cache you can
click on search results and view this
yourself but this is an important thing
for SEO is to understand that search
engines are not necessarily in fact most
the time they are not working on your
live site they're only working on a copy
of it that they have on their own
servers and this is going to have small
differences like personalization they're
going to crawl from set locations so
they're not going to have a personalized
to every single location than a user a
real human being might visit your
website from so search engines do not
work off of your live site they only
work off copies of it luckily for us we
have access to that by you by looking in
the cache which is provided to us the
third phase in this is by far the most
complex it's to the processing in the
indexing phase now this happens in many
different phases itself this is
something that happens in many different
data centers around the world and quite
frankly this is where all the magic
happens this is where the billion-dollar
algorithms go in to try to extract
signals that can be used to figure out
the best information on the Internet
the important thing to understand now is
that this is a process that is mostly
hidden to markers and to the general
public it's hidden in the vaults and on
the computers of computer scientists all
over the globe the last phase is the one
that you're probably already familiar
with its rankings so at this point a
user has typed something into a search
engine they're getting the results back
and the search engine needs to rank all
the results all the possible results
they could have on the Internet
to something that is most relevant for
the given phrase that was typed in now
this is a very very complex thing that
happens ridiculously fast so what
happens is the query the query gets sent
to the search engine servers it's
already stored that the information is
already indexed then the ranking
algorithms have taken effect and these
use lots and lots of signals this this
number is ever-increasing but things
like time things like current events
things like personalization things like
your past to history of searching all of
these things are taking into account in
quite literally milliseconds and the
result is shown so you can find the like
closest Krispy Kreme donuts
four major search engine processes are
crawling storing processing and indexing
and ranking crawlers scour the Internet
by going to a website downloading its
content and then following the links it
finds on the given pages to other pages
it then repeats this process search
engines store a copy of a subset of the
publicly accessible data on your server
search engines use their indices to rank
order relevant results given user
queries
you